[Music]
love blinded me my love for this city my
love for her and the devil took my
throne my freedom and everything that
matters but my eyes are open now and
he'll never see me coming
so go ahead
let the devil out
[Music]
Oh
things to see it's not just you
[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie time to let
the devil out we got a kingpin trailer
for daredevil season 3 a whole bunch of
new footage and there's even more stuff
that they dropped it's separate from
these trailers that I posted here
speaking of kingpin there's a new round
of that spider-man ps4 game giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video uh name a new winner at the end of
this I think it was one of the previous
daredevil trailers that I posted where I
talked a little bit about how this
kingpin is different from our daredevil
season 3 kingpin he's still on the rise
he's just out of prison in like he says
the devil took my throne from me but
he'll never see me coming
so let the devil out like this is all
about the rise of the kingpin like if
Wilson Fisk hadn't officially become the
kingpin as of the end of season one or
season two he will officially become the
kingpin during season 3
you probably detected on the heavy
metaphors about black-white good/bad
Devils angels the whole thing here being
that they're both rising to the occasion
and letting their inner Devils out like
Matt is literally the devil of Hell's
Kitchen but there was that earlier clip
where he talked about how it was better
to die as the devil than live is Matt
Murdock so him throwing his bloody white
shirt and his glasses into the furnace
there is him burning his identity of
Matt Murdock leaving that behind I'm
completely the devil of Hell's Kitchen
this season the kingpin though is
wearing white on top of black so he's
just cloaking his identity as the devil
but remember the painting from season 1
the white painting that he bought from
Vanessa and how important that was to
him how he felt like it was such a
peaceful tranquil simple idea so you see
a bunch of different clips here with him
looking like he's under house arrest
he's still wearing what looks like a
prison uniform but he's in a high-rise
apartment staring at this white wall so
this might be in the in-between period
when he's still getting ready to stand
trial and get out of prison but he's not
scot-free yet because you see that house
arrest bracelet when he walks into the
shower so it's not like episode 1 picks
up and he's scot-free look you see him
step out onto the street here and
there's all these picketers that are
really pissed off about him
whole idea that he's on the path to
taking control officially and
unofficially like the underground the
criminal world of New York City in
Manhattan like you see him at the
beginning of spider-man ps4 like he has
this worldwide crime network but within
the context of the Netflix universe
Jeff lobe the president of Marvel TV
said they already had tentative plans
for daredevil season four and five so I
think that just means that he's gonna
continue to build his worldwide criminal
network because without doing a bunch of
spoilers for the other Netflix series
they all leave the different defenders
characters in interesting places but I
think the whole idea is is that because
you have all these different boroughs of
New York City
eventually the kingpin of crime-- will
become the kingpin of the entire city
not just Manhattan but I love the slow
montage here this sort of gives you a
bit of a recap for where he's been the
last couple of seasons like you see him
pumping iron walking into a cell the
devil took my freedom from me you seen a
staring at this picture here in the
white costume this actually might be
Matt Murdock's picture as the devil of
Hell's Kitchen this might be him
figuring out that they're both the same
person the devil can't hide for me he'll
never see me coming then you cut to that
picture of Matt all bloodied up in his
lawyer suit not knowing what's going on
so that might be after kingpin really
starts to go after him and like you see
him in this convoy here with a car in
front of them blowing up it might be
part of his plot to discredit the devil
of Hell's Kitchen to turn him into what
looks like a criminal so the FBI will go
after him and do his dirty work for him
why would Wilson Fisk who's trying to
make everyone think that he has been
right this whole time he's been falsely
accused of all these crimes against him
even though we totally know he's guilty
best way to make himself seem like the
victim in all this is make the devil of
Hell's Kitchen seem like the villain so
because he doesn't look surprised at all
when the car in front of them is blowing
up like he expected this to happen maybe
it's part of his fake daredevil plot to
discredit Matt like you hired the fake
daredevil to go around killing people
and try to kill Wilson Fisk like look
the devil of Hell's Kitchen is trying to
kill me he must be the criminal in all
this I've been falsely accused
we'll just keep using the Ben Affleck
daredevil as the quote/unquote fake
daredevil I don't actually know who's
gonna be playing that role on the TV
show but because they're doing born
again we see
footage we know that they're gonna be
doing that part of the comic book story
I know there are a lot of people to
think that it's gonna be bullseye though
the actor this playing the bullseye
character will be one of the fake
Daredevils but that remains to be seen I
haven't seen any actual footage of the
actor who plays him in any of this yet
outside of the FBI footage he could be
underneath one of these masks here from
the last big trailer so let me know in
the comments what are you most hyped up
about remember it's gonna be dropping at
the end of October so we're gonna get
another really big trailer in New York
Comic Con next week like a real big
trailer will you'll see foggy and matte
like there a couple pictures that
they've already dropped you see Karen
talking to him here while he's in his
black costume you see him talking to
foggy in the bar here why is trying to
keep it on the DL so it might be right
after he resurfaces or right after the
kingpin starts to put a hit out on him
and the devil of Hell's Kitchen at the
same time we also got our first look at
his mother mother Maggie talking to him
here so it doesn't look like she's too
happy with what he's doing maybe he's in
the middle of training or something like
that but this is him at that convent
where he landed at the end of defenders
last season so everybody get hype as
soon as the embargo is up I'll post my
non-spoilery review usually that happens
the week before it officially releases
but we'll see it might be a little bit
earlier than that because I think
everybody just really excited for
daredevil to get here there was some
brand new spider-man far from home
footage they dropped of him in the new
costume so I'll do a new video for that
on Saturday leave all your requests in
the comments below
Laoghaire davis congratulations you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here to rewatch the new x-men Dark
Phoenix trailer and click here for that
new venom trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight